[Musique]
let's go
le smartphone est vraiment magnifique
vous avez ici sur le bouton sur le côté
pour savoir s'ils veulent mettre en mode
vibration silencieux ou avec la sonnerie
le bouton pour l'allumer pour l'éteindre
un capteur d'empreintes digitales qui va
extrêmement vite un haut parleur ici
vous avez un deuxième haut parleurs de
ski situées là surtout le bon choix si
vous voyez bien de la recharge en usb
c'est vous avez ici double lecteur de
carte sim dos à dos ils surent côté vous
avez le bouton de volume sur le dessus
la petite caméra tractable le micro
antibruit l'autre micro qui est situé
juste en dessous à l'arrière triple
module photo un dos qui n'est pas du
tout brillant qui est très mat avec des
effets de lumière plus bleus tient peu
plus sur le bleu foncé
je trouve vraiment très jolie il ya un
côté un peu incurvé très bien dessiné il
se prend bien en main alors très
clairement c'est un smartphone qui est
grand il faut utiliser à demain il est
vraiment super beau et surtout ce que je
trouve vraiment génial qui est déjà
testée lors de la première prise en main
deux fois c'est ça la ça c'est génial
la prison m'a écoule tout con c'est
quand même de le protéger alors à
l'intérieur vous avez une coque de
protection transparente qui est bon sur
le principe bien c'est bien qu'elle soit
là alors le côté positif de cette coque
transparente c'est qu'effectivement et
bien votre smartphone va devoir sortir
et vous ne verrez bien comme ça ce qui
est marrant aussi avec 7 comme classe
qui effectivement est bien la caméra
voyez il ya la petite place pour qu'elle
puisse sortir up et qu'elle puisse
rentrer et dans mon coffret il ya aussi
une petite languette
[Musique]
dans lequel j'ai trouvé de cocker de
quoi vous êtes vous retrouvée d'un
commerce plutôt sympa là il ya un peu de
matière j'aime bien ce touché la khl
amateurs très sympa ça c'est un côté qui
est un peu plus doux moi j'ai toujours
une préférence sur ce type de bâtir là
je trouve ça vraiment canon
comme on est aujourd'hui aussi mais que
le smartphone est présenté dans quelques
jours la semaine prochaine le 14 mai à
londres
je préfère me balader avec une petite
coque il va rester très discret dans ma
poche personne sera jugée le plus est
avec moi que je le teste est forcément
pour le tester il faut pouvoir l'avoir
avec soi ça c'est ma vidéo donne boxing
je vous invite à regarder ma vidéo de
test qui suit juste après comme ça vous
saurez exactement ce que je pense du one
piece est après plusieurs heures
d'utilisation vous invite dès maintenant
posez toutes vos questions commentaires
on parle du one piece est dit pas
comment vous trouvez
est-ce que vous prouver bien qu est ce
que vous pensez de cette caméra
rétractable est ce que vous trouvez ça
cool oui non quoi comment je vais
regarder la vidéo suivante c'est mon
test dure une puce est comme ça vous
nous dire ce que vous en pensez